♪ (ELECTRONIC MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
-GIRL: Want to go
on the Graviton?
-RUE BENNETT: Uh, no.
-The Ferris wheel?
-Nope.
-Why?
-Because I don't wanna die.
(SCREAMING, LAUGHTER)
SAM LEVINSON: Episode four is
one of the more personal
episodes of the show for me.
When you're young and it's like,
the carnival's in town,
it's always this major event,
and you know
everyone's gonna be there.
(GIGGLING)
MARCELL RÉV: Sam had the idea
to create a setting
that can be dreamy
but based in reality,
and a small-time carnival
is a place like that.
It's essentially a somewhat
psychedelic or-- or like
deeply experiential,
altered state that's going on.
RÉV:
Lots of colored, cool lights,
you can imagine certain things
to happen there,
which won't happen
in other places.
Hey. I'm really scared.
Hands and feet inside the ride.
(SCREAMING)
Marcel, myself and Peter Beck,
our storyboard artist, sat down
and basically storyboarded
a carnival that didn't exist.
So, it was a massive thing
to coordinate.
They had essentially built
their own carnival.
They rented all the equipment,
all the rides, everything.
RÉV: They built the carnival
like two days
before we started shooting
so we spent some time there,
figuring out shots,
trying to adjust
our storyboards
to the actual location.
LEVINSON:
It was kind of conceived
as an oblong-esque carnival
in which we're able
to continually track through it.
So we could always be shooting
Rue something.
We could have foreground
and background.
We could utilize our extras
in a way
that gave it sort of real scope.
Welcome to Pretzelmania.
Can I take your order?
We started to shoot the carnival
with the smaller scenes,
like the more intimate scenes.
It was almost every single shot
was
300 feet of dolly track we'd lay
and then we'd shoot a scene
looking one way.
And then,
we'd flip the dolly around
and shoot it the other way.
So, we had like two days
while shooting after we wrapped,
the day we started to figure out
this opening shot.
Yeah. It's gonna be a good night
tonight, man.
Let's get this money.
The concept was to create
a shot that connects
all the characters.
You know, we had-- I think,
figured out a way
to weave through this thing
and to really reveal the space
step by step
with the characters and sort of
see it with the characters.
Sam wanted it to feel like
it was one shot, and it's not.
We shot it, I think,
in five different pieces.
JULIO PEREZ:
You can look into it and see
where certain edit points
might be,
but it's very hard to find it.
LEVINSON: The design
of the entire carnival
was how can we achieve
everything in these single shots
so we can feel the flow of it.
PEREZ: The material was like
coming in, and we'd look at it,
just like-- going like,
"Wow, this shot is phenomenal."
RÉV: It's a tough thing
for everyone to create
a technically complicated shot
like that,
but yeah,
they did a really great job.
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪